I have a feeling I know the answer to
this question but what is something that
you've done for a movie or a TV show
that now makes you think really cool
that I did that but I'm never gonna do
it again
screaming for my life is something that
I've done enough of not a point to get
rid of horror all together because I
just watched dr. sleep the other night I
loved it so good I think
horror films are so rich and they're so
fun to watch I love them so much so I'm
not pooh-poohing on horror films I'm
just saying I'm not sure I want to spend
a whole three months of my life running
and screaming for survival very
understandable so with that in mind we
do know about Evil Dead now yeah Lee
Cronin who I'm a huge fan of if he
happened to say hey why don't we bring
Mia back for another movie would you be
interested
no get it that that movie that movie was
a lot yeah exhausting I'm so proud of it
like it's such a wild movie but I think
you know I think
it's
okay moving on it's the blood rain and
all that I get it